willkommen zum Q&A zu der Reportage
Diabetes Burnout wenn Zuckerkrankheit
bestimmt er mal viele viele Dank für die
zahlreiche Kommentar und Frage wo gangen
sind
beantwortte vi h mir auch i eig
Erlaubnis und erfahige mit Diabetes
verzählt eine ist Mira 24 sie schribt
ich bin jetzt 3 und so sehr meinem
Körper so geschadet zu haben ich spüre
meine Zehen nicht mehr muss spezielle
Schuhe tragen und habe dauernd
Beschwerden ich hatte gut 8 Jahre nie
ein HbA1c unter ne ich würde so gerne
zurück und meinem jungen ich eine riesen
umarmen geben und die Kraft um zu
realisieren dass die Ärzte mir helfen
wollten ja das ist eine von der
Kommentar wo mich wirklich ja schockiert
hät m das mit 3 schon so schlimme
vololge schade h das S einfach ja eine
schmeewach grüelt wahrscheinlich auch
paar andere Diabetikerinnen und
Diabetiker da der Kommentar zeigt
einfach wirklich egal wie unsichtbar
krankit schiint Diabetes kann wirklich
gefählich werden wenn man sich nicht
drum kümmert ja ich persönlich erknnis
braucht z dem Diabetes bnout
und Z mich zam
so krasse Sachen gehöre oder auch seeh
zu mich ja andere g
BP mir ist immer Gesit wde von
Diabetologin wenn hab z tfer wird z den
Sie dass ich meine fahrprf muss
abgeen und ja das wirk so dankt nein oh
Gott das W nicht also ja das wir braucht
also ich verstah es dass dass es B ein
vielleicht nicht funktioniert aber bei
mir das funktioniert viele h sich auch
nach der Reportage verstandlicherwies
gefragt ja was kann wir denn machen zum
betroffen unterstützen wie z. B Stefanie
525 sie schiebt wie kann man Betroffene
bestmöglich unterstützen damit sie nicht
ins Burnout geraten ist dies überhaupt
möglich also ich aus me Sicht sage was
für m nicht brucht
h ja das FT mir irgendwie einfacher also
es unbedingt vermet werde ist Druck W V
frunde ter und Ärzt Druck ausgt wde ist
auf mich dann hab ich
schcht nicht richtig machen was sicher
hilft ist aufmerksam sie und wenn man
merkt hey die Person ist eventuell im
Diabetes Burnout den
direktpreche kanama machen und sich
eventuell vor drüber informieren und
alle Elter wo vermutet dass Kind
Diabetes burnout ist also ja so Sache
verbiet
undper bringt Sicht auch nicht und
zwanghaft kontrollieren auch nicht was
sicher hilft sind Gespräch g die
Lebensmittel dahi und
aususch mit de diabetolog ich habe die
Frage gerne SAR Stellen mit
Protagonistin aus der Reportage und
darum hab ich im Vorfeld n mit ihrer
telefoniert
wie gut danke ein Thema wo
rechtestoch
Block psychologische
Unterstützig da dazu zwei Kommentar der
erste von der la zitolina sie schribt
dass das Insulin produzierende Organ vom
Körper selber zerstört wird den das
glaub ich auch nicht d sobald der heilig
ge wird ich denke es wird wirklich
wichtig für Zara die krank zu
akzeptieren das ist der erste Schritt
auf dem Weg zum Umgang damit Problem
verdangen und sich ibildde stü die über
der Tatsache macht's nur schlimmer weiß
nicht ob du den Kommentar geseh
h was also was macht das mit dir wenn
das jetzt so
gehörst ich denke es kom immer ob die
Person selber Diabetes hat oder nicht
und es ist mir überl W ich mich
begleiten möchte für mich ist ich habe
psychologische hilf will ich immer so
die Star sie und das ist jetzt riesen
Prozess für mich das Ganze zu und mir
sage hey ja ich hab Diabetes und logisch
das ist jetzt ein ein Schritt für nach
teilig Dash ich schon auch so aber ist
ein nicht möglich für
mich andere Person
farbdupfli 161
wird Sarah auch psychologisch begleitet
davon war in der Dock keine rede ich bin
keine Spezialistin aber ich glaube sie
braucht das wirklich Hilfe von außen
alsoleid vielleicht nicht nur in Bezug
auf Diabetes die psychologische hilf
zolle oder w du das wirklichber tant ich
finde es ist ein legitimer Kommentar was
ich aber viel wichtiger finde als mir
hilf im Holle ich mir selber wieder
zulass und wieder mich selber zu köen
und hey was brauche ich um mich den Art
von Meer innere Sache könen leit das ist
für mich jetzt wichtiger als irg
sprachstund und verzäh was m Problem ist
sondern es ist mir wichtiger dass ich
mir selber wieder
zulasse und also das Trigger oder
verletze wenn so die kom dar kör oder
kan es nur
nachvollziehen nein das verletzt mich
nicht ich find ich find wenn ich v w se
wür ich auch sagen oh mein Gott was
hätten dir oder aber da ich mich selber
jetzt mittlerweile gut kan muss ich
sagen ich ma me weg und ja ich ma das
was für mich
passtm W sag es got mittlerw besser im
Vergleich zu jetzt wenn tre ist zwar
noch nicht viel Zeit Verb
Unterschied ja definitiv also ich meine
der Reportage sind einfach ja nicht
ganze le W zeigt wde ist und so bin ich
ein sehr glücklicher Mensch das ist ein
Teil wo ja zu le
gehört und von dem her W ich jetzt nicht
sagen dass alles
scheiße ein nur ein
Teil den es ist Folge direkt dan D von
der Denis
iris0 sie wir einfach schlicht und weg
interessierere wie habt ihr euer
Diabetes erkannt mir leistsabfall so es
ist 6 Schul
sondern und so und körperliche
dazu me
durch wie Wasser trinken
und
okay danke s noch mal für die Offenheit
ich glaube wir bliben den Kontakt oder
und wün dir für Zukunft alles Gute sehr
gern danke viel mal dir und dir n das
beste so das ist m Gespräch mit der
sarie was aber auch recht z r h in die
kommentarsparte ist Begriff Diabetes
Burnout Chrissy schriebt
m was ich mich frage und da hätte ich
mir die Stimme einer Fachperson aus der
Psychopathologie gewünscht im Film ist
Burnout der passende Begriff für alles
im Film gezeigte und CH n F beschriebt
ich wäre vorsichtig mit einer Burnout
Diagnose also es ist mir bewusst dass
der Begriff Diabetes Burnout der Schwiz
nur recht unbekannt ist deswegen ist
auch umso wichtiger
der Begriff in Reportage der L bringen
Diabetes Bern bezieht sich ja auf
psychische emotionale belastig fr eine
Person über längere zit erschöpft
überfordert und frustriert über die
standige Kontrolle und behandl vom
Diabetes ist das ist also bei mir und
der Lisa definitiv der Fall wie man
gesehen hat und mit der Sar ja auch das
ja sie und ihre diabetolog könen
bestätigen
ja sie befet sich Hal wirklich Diabetes
Burnout und ein ganz offizielle
Definition V Diabetes Burnout geht aber
n will es sich Hal wirklich von Person
zu Person anders
auswirken ich verstah dass der Begriff
Tri ich hab Verlauf der Reportage aber
auch no mit früh diabetolog geredet und
inucht und auch er mein dass Begriff
oder Informationen ü Diabetes Burnout
noch nicht wirklich sind da einchnitt
vff es gibt wenig Informationen über den
Burnout aber ich denke dass ich wie du
sag ein Tabu oder mit Scham oder mit
Verlierer Gefühle verbunden so dass mir
denus paar hemmige h quasi an die
Öffentlichkeit oder sich quasi mit der
Gedanken steil eigentlich in der Epoche
wo du auch eigentlich schon drinestckt
bist mit der Diagnose Internet mit
Social Media und mehrere Plattformen wo
mehrere Interessenten Gruppen einand
findet die dem Kontext ist es mega
schwierig einfach die öffentlichkeits
sousage und sage ja ich habe jetzt
einfach Burnout oder ich mag ich mag
jetzt einfach n me und ich weiß n mehr
wie mir Helfe oder was auch immer und
ich habe Verlierer Gefühle od war das
man gro Glock
his dem hat Diabetes K unterscheiden
zwischen zwei te und grob Symptom Ken
aufzellen und obwohl ja kein offizielle
Definition V Diabetes GT kan B
unterscheiden und man kan
auchszeichen das vielfältig se du kan
einfach es K alle sicherer brennen will
du im Loch steck und machtlos bist und
ohmächtig und nicht im Stand bist quasi
zu de Sache Z l und rrig bist aber e es
kann auch se dass du Burnout h will du
ein
pinkelige strebige Persönlichkeit h wo
einfach V sichus alles perfekt will hab
und den perfekte Zucker ist nie perfekt
und denn kann man sich wie das Netz
irgendwie verfangen in dem dass man das
Gefühl hte ich m noch mehr und noch mehr
und noch mehr und am Ende geht mir alles
auf oder mir seit sich ich B für nichts
wert will ich das nicht schaffe noch
besser zu werde und dann am Ende wird
meim leiterlich Spiele wieder quasi
zurück auf Feld 1 und der Diabetes ist
mega schlecht ein ander Aspekt wo ich
auch da gern wür thematisi ist die ganze
Technik vi ja g das ist ja gerade geht
wo alles automatisch möcht und da dazu W
einfach gerne anmerken neug gerad butet
nicht unbedingt dass es einfacher oder
besser ist für die Person also es muss
jeder salberue finde was zu einem passt
und ja mit alle in andere Körper wenn es
anders empfinde ja W da alle andere
Lebensumstand und da h Linda 386 e z.B
der Kommentar geschben eine Pumpe hatte
ich auch mal bin allerdings wieder auf
Penn umgestiegen da es mich persönlich
sehr gestört hat etwas immer am Körper
tragen zu müssen den Pen kann ich nach
dem Spritzen weglassen und den Diabetes
für eine Weile auch mal vergessen also
aber für die einte bedüet ne die Technik
und die neuste grad nicht unbedingt dass
es in lichterig ist also wenn ich das
jetzt vergliche zwischen Spritze und
pumpi pumpi muss man standig auswechsel
man
muss oder ich muss immer das zusatzg B
haben wie M dieabetes Handy das
diabetesy muss auch immer Akku hab muss
immer Akkulader dabi
man muss l dass man die Sachen nicht a
Vers vom Körper
rie und ganz ehrlich oft nicht Verlass
auf die Technik und das hab ich vor paar
Tag auch
gemerkt mit neue Pumpe W ich 50 Cent
Konzert ich B mit der
Kollegin die
Dosis ja und dann sind später
maladionang
und wie ausg also flaster ist wie ganz
nass gie und ja natürlich kan ich kein
Ersatz
der ja ich muss F lernen und ja da bin
ich einfach halt D Stunden lang überzck
dem
Konzert halb Stund gefühlt W m aber hab
jetzt nicht das Konzert GAL und he jetzt
kein Ersatz haben also wie gesagt neue
Technik ist gut für die ein für die
andere nö aber es bedutet nicht
unbedingt dass
weniger Nachteil hät und zum Schluss
würde ich nur
gern dir Kommentar lass der
von der rompe KAB sachsis danke als
nichtdiabetikerin habe ich gerade viel
gelernt und habe großen Respekt vor
diesen Menschen die tagtäglich mit
dieser Krankheit umgehen müssen und
lenus 4148 schribt Fachfrau habe ich
tagtäglich mit Menschen zu tun die mit
dieser Krankheit konfrontiert sind diese
Reportage ist aber so eindrücklich und
persönlich gemacht dass ich nochmals
einen ganz anderen Blick auf die
Krankheit bekommen habe und hoffe meine
Patient ihnen noch besser betreuen zu
können also ich habe wirklich freut dass
auch nicht
Diabetiker und
i Diabetiker und Diabetikerin auf
die genau ihr sind umfallt und ich find
auch schön wenn wenn ihr wüsstet wie s g
od wen ihr wüst was es bedeutet mit
Diabetes so damit W ich am Schluss vom
Q&A danke viel viel mal für L und fürs
kommentier wenn ihr gerade da sind
gerade Kanal abonnieren die Reportage
und das Q&A hab wir übrigens auch auf
SRF
play